the Oakland chapter of the NAACP is fed
up with the Anarchy created by the
city's stopped on crime policies the
head of the group blasting local
officials and even calling for a state
of emergency to be declared adding quote
failed leadership including the movement
to defund the police our district
attorney's unwillingness to charge and
prosecute people who murder and commit
life-threatening serious crimes and the
proliferation of anti-police rhetoric
have created a Heyday for Oakland
criminals it is not racist or unkind to
want to be safe from crime in July alone
Oakland has seen a 15 increase in
violent crime compared to last year and
residents are sick of it
how do we stop this hamster wheel of
crime because that's really the question
please drive around and pick a victim
and it's it's just it's getting scary
what are we doing to address this and
how do we solve this nobody feels safe
so Jesse during the height of the defund
the police movement the NAACP stopped
short of calling for Devon nipples but
they just engaged in all of the rhetoric
that led to the exact thing and now
unfortunately there have been
consequences the Oakland Dublin NCP or
whatever I'm sorry NAACP I almost said
na wait is it NCAA
insurance commercial aren't you that's
liberty liberty liberty
they were they wanted to redirect money
from the police that old Kamala Harris
gag and now they're begging for the
police to come and save their lives it's
happening all over the country look at
San Francisco did the same thing and now
instead of actually trying to fight
crime they're locking up ice cream same
thing happened in Philadelphia and now
tranx taking over and people are walking
around with flesh-eating viruses what
happened in New York City they were like
oh yeah we're a sanctuary city until all
the illegals came here now it's like a
slumber party on the sidewalk there's
prostitution in Queens like Amsterdam
and now the mayor's like we don't want
to be a sanctuary City anymore where in
Queens
I'll tell you after and what happened in
Washington D.C did you know that the
Mexican Government is issuing a travel
advisory for Mexicans warning them that
Washington DC is dangerous so these
Democrats are destroying the cities and
then when everyone's putting up their
hands and saying can you guys do
something about that they'll talk about
reparations the only person and they're
basically
Prosecuting is Trump yeah Dana but it
doesn't isn't this the way this has to
happen with the local community yeah
going to those meetings and saying
change it and you know think about how
many meetings have you been to right
like it takes a lot to get people to go
to a meeting and to know that they're
going to be on camera and to get up
there so one they're fearful for their
lives and the lives of their children
also their property values are in the
tank so they're looking at their
retirement funds or their kids education
funds going down plus and we did a story
last week on Newsroom that still has my
mind reeling in 2020 right before the
pandemic The Chronic absenteeism rate in
Baltimore County Schools was 23 percent
that means you're missing 10 or more of
school guess what it is today
eight percent yeah yeah okay so you take
that plus the fact that you have a major
youth violence problem there and the
same thing was happening in Baltimore
you had black citizens saying we need to
be tougher on crime so I do think that
the more you see these local local
people yelling at their local officials
that you might actually be able to
affect some change they're going to have
to keep it up Jessica your thoughts on
this process
um consequences for actions
definitely consequences I don't think
it's
a straight line from the summer of 2020.
I mean these are no I'm saying that
these are problems that have gone back
further than that this is a much longer
trend line than just George Floyd has
murdered and suddenly these cities are
cesspools but this is certainly not the
promise of liberalism and that's what
these voters are saying they're not
saying I'm a republican now they are not
going to vote for a republican but they
want Democrats that are going to talk
about the real issues that are
confronting them on a daily basis and I
don't think democrats should be afraid
of that frankly that's how you win back
your seats like the four congressional
seats that we lost here in New York was
all because of crime I talked to Liz
Alden when he was here one time
um about this and he said I just had to
show up at these meetings and people
poured out their concerns did all of
them vote for me absolutely not but they
clearly wanted to have a conversation
the Democrats were not open to I do
think with defund the police though that
it's one of these moments and there are
a few kind of Flashpoint issues around
the country where this happens where the
activist class is not speaking the same
language as the regular people I I don't
go to a lot of City Council meetings
necessarily but I know a lot of people
who live in cities and not a single one
of them ever said I want to defund the
police or I want to take away their
resources so I think the activist class
really needs to get on the same page as
those people who are turning up at
meetings so Greg is there a direct line
between summer 20 and 2020 to the crime
now I would say there is yeah I think so
it and I think uh and then when you
started to point it out and I know that
this happened here at times they would
they would link the rise in crime to the
lockdowns and perhaps there was some
evidence there maybe but when the
lockdowns were over the crime was never
worse got worse it's not like the crime
went away what's frustrating is if you
did point it out you were called racist
but who were the truly racist people
were the people that were conflating Law
and Order with whiteness and crime to
Blackness it's not it's not it's not us
Republicans are conservatives
Libertarians do that that was the hard
left and it's a circular argument that
prevents any kind of solutions the
funding police affects minorities their
neighborhoods get hit the worst point
that out that blacks are the victims you
will be deemed racist that mere
observation is a problem so the that
that prevents the so-called conversation
remember everybody wants to have we just
need a conversation you can't have a
conversation on crime because the the
left through their prism of identity
politics has made it impossible to see
beyond the pigment of criminals and
victims in fact the pigment only matters
with criminals but it doesn't matter
with victims at least be consistent yeah
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcaneny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 pm Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights